our very own Sarah Carter she traveled
to havid or she caught up with a
research associate who's not happy with
the conduct of their president but does
not want her face uh of any kind or any
of these kids to be disciplined take a
look even Harvard presidents are not
perfect okay and she was overly primed
by her lawyers and she you know she
didn't say the right thing okay so but
it doesn't mean she she should be
punished with resignation she's going to
learn you know I think she was uh Sid
swiped by that
question all right here with more from
our trip to Cambridge our very own Sarah
Carter Sarah to me there's there's no
there's no moral ambiguity here this is
moral Clarity either Harvard stands
against uh murder and rape and torture
and terrorism and kidnapping or they
don't this was not a deep question that
she was being asked here and the thing
is if you apply the standard of Elise
stonic question to any other quote
identity group you tell me uh would
there be consequences to any student at
Harvard well absolutely Sean she's also
not a sh a child she knew she was
testifying before Congress and she had
to prepare to testify before Congress so
this wasn't a trick question you know
many of the students that I interviewed
here in Cambridge uh also made excuses
for president gay they they said you
know she was caught off guard she didn't
really know what she was saying and what
I found really surprising Sean was the
fact that it was difficult for many of
the students to actually answer the very
simple question our calls for genocide
against the Jewish people against and
violating the code of conduct here at
Harvard University take a listen do you
feel though that her inability to
respond to whether or not genocide the
calls for genocide um violated the
ethical code of standard here at Harvard
uh exposed that maybe she was wavering
on a subject that should have been very
simple to answer
um I do not know enough about that to
comment to be able to comment fully to
be honest personally I think that it's
important for University leadership to
be held accountable but I also think
that she has tried really hard to like
fix the mistakes she made and I do
believe that she did make mistakes like
as an administrator but I think it's
wrong it's it'd be wrong to just get rid
of her just because she made these
mistakes and it's important for her to
show that like she's ready to learn and
grow from like the mistakes that she
made I can't like I'm not I feel
indifferent I mean the the corporation
Harvard supports genocide so I mean
whoever's the face of the institution
doesn't really matter so you felt like
her testimony wasn't so much offensive
it's just oh it's bad it was bad her
testimony was
awful Sean there are a number of major
Harvard donors who are not going to let
president gay slide in fact one of them
is billionaire Bill Amman who stated
that he will no longer be donating to
Harvard as long as they keep uh
president gay in her position of power
after her anti-semitic testimony and he
assessed that1 billion dollar in
donations have already been pulled from
Harvard from Elma moer and other donors
Jewish as well as other non-jewish
donors that would have been donating to
the campus Sean all right great report
Sarah Carter at Harvard tonight thank
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else